so were you surprised when these reports
came out when you haven't made a
decision that
seemingly others say you have
there's always a good line that
you know i'm responsible for what i say
and do and um and not responsible for
what others say or do so
again i think one thing i've learned
about sports is you know you control
what you can control
and you know what you can't you leave to
others
here to break it all down legendary
sportscaster friend of the program fox
news sports analyst the host of the
podcast let's go with tom brady
available by the way on apple wherever
your stream uh wherever you're streaming
your podcast
jim is friends and has been friends with
tom brady and by the way jim is friends
with everybody because jim is like the
nicest guy you'd ever want to meet um
and there's a lot of good guys in in
sports jim nance is a great guy you're a
great guy al michaels is a great guy
um you know i'm sure i'm forgetting some
people here but you know it's it's an
interesting crowd but all right so
you're friends with tom you do this
podcast with them how often do you do it
we've done it the past 12 years together
on monday night football and now on
siriusxm let's go on siriusxm the
podcast is available it's with tom brady
myself and larry fitzgerald so we've
done it for a long time
all right so
the speculation comes out the reports
came out i'll be honest i was surprised
i he had one of the best seasons
statistically that he's ever had and i'm
thinking no why is he retiring he's at
the top of his game i know he probably
he wants to be in the super bowl
it was such a great comeback he came
that close i couldn't believe it it was
one of the more exciting all these
playoff games have been amazing um and i
just i don't it's like that rocky moment
when he says i still have stuff in the
basement i'm hoping tom has stuff in the
basement what did he tell you
well he said tonight that he has not
come to a decision that he is taking it
day-to-day and then when he makes a
decision he will let us all know he said
last week that he has two loves and
obviously we've all known that for a
long time he loves football and he loves
his family he also said that his family
needs him and it's not just about what
he wants to do but what they all want to
do as a family so he's weighing this all
out he's number one in all the
statistical categories he possibly is an
mvp probably aaron rodgers and and tom
will finish second in the voting but at
44 years of age he said he would quit
when he sucks well he certainly doesn't
suck but certainly all of these other
things come into play he's been in 10
super bowls he's played and won seven of
them
so you know he will just decide whether
or not he wants to go through this
entire process again and at 44 years of
age
he's entitled to do that he has earned
the right and the respect of all of us
to let him make his own announcement i
listened to a lot of the podcast he sent
me clips and he gave you a pretty good
answer on why no decision yet and he
also responded to the unfortunate
speculation tell us what he told you
well he didn't want to upstage or have
this upset all of the guys in the nfl
who worked so hard to be in the afc
championship in the nfc championship
game he doesn't want to be the center of
attention he would be the center of
attention if he was in the game but
unfortunately for him the buccaneers
lost last week to uh through the rams
and the rams have now advanced so he's
not about upstaging anybody he's had
more attention than anybody could have
for the past 40 lifetimes so it's not
about all of that to him so and he's
just on his own timetable you don't do
something for 30 years
and and be as proficient and as great as
he had and then all of a sudden reach a
decision overnight he needs some space
he needs some time he doesn't want to
make an emotional decision he wants to
think it through he wants to discuss it
with his family
he has teammates obviously he has an
organization and he has a business so
everybody has to be taken into account
so there is no rush uh the buccaneers
don't have to know for quite a while
here
as to what the plans are for tom so
he'll take his time and and he may end
up not coming back or he may end up
playing neither would surprise me but he
certainly he certainly once again uh
sean has earned the right to make his
own decision on his own timetable and
not to be pushed into something or or
have to respond to everything that comes
out at every moment he didn't sound
angry or bitter he just said it was
unfortunate that the media rushed with
the news that wasn't news uh so he had a
pretty good i thought pretty objective
attitude we got about 20
seconds he understands what's going on
and he understands what's going on in
the media landscape and he also
understand that these guys are doing
their jobs and they're probably doing
their jobs to the best of their ability
and that's the information that they had
that doesn't mean that it's right and it
doesn't mean that it's right at this
moment may turn out right
we don't know i don't know uh all i know
is that when he makes a decision we'll
all be informed and he hasn't done that
yet
um selfishly i love watching him play i
like to see him come back jim greg good
to see you my friend hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else